you
hi everyone hello
okay
all right just one update for all of you
at the top um
president is always is obviously quite
focused on the american jobs plan that
he just announced last
week as you all know he's already had
two bipartisan congressional meetings on
infrastructure in the oval office and he
plans to continue speaking with leaders
from both sides of the aisle to get
their input either on the phone this
week or when they return he looks
forward to welcoming
members to the oval office again uh and
this work is being supported of course
by the jobs cabinet many of you may have
seen
members of the jobs cabinet out over the
weekend speaking
on your airwaves directly to the
american people
and the jobs cabinet members have also
been active and engaging with members of
congress
on both sides of the aisle and they will
continue to play that role
over the course of the coming weeks and
months so jobs cabinet members sedate
have made 56 calls to the
28 democrats and 28 republicans who are
the chairs and ranking members on
relevant committees uh they have held
we've held briefings with the entire
house and senate
invited the house briefing had 124
representatives on including 31
republicans senior white house officials
have briefed bipartisan working groups
in both chambers
including the group of 20 senators and
the problem solvers
caucus and as i noted president looks
forward to welcoming
members when they return next week with
that
alex go ahead thanks uh i have a couple
of questions on the infrastructure and
jobs plan
uh one on uh immigration okay to start
the jobs plan has been receiving
opposition from both the left and the
right um
on the right this weekend senator roy
blunt said that it would be an easy
bipartisan win if the bill were more
rarely focused
so why not reduce the bill down to just
infrastructure and take up planks like
the care workers and the
electric vehicle aspects um and then in
addition to that
on the left senator joe manchin said
today that he can't support a 28
uh tax increase on corporations so is
the white house open
to lowering that he said the highest he
would support is 25
well first on the infrastructure uh
question let me say
that uh some republicans who have been
vocal
think investing in water systems and
replacing pipes so americans can have
clean drinking water
is not infrastructure but the president
does some don't think investing in high
speed rail is infrastructure
the president does some believe building
charging stations to support
america's electric vehicle future is not
infrastructure
he believes it is uh some don't believe
that america's broadband capacity
uh which is one-third of the american of
america the american people i should say
don't have access to broadband
and improving those lines and expanding
that access is not infrastructure the
president
does some believe that addressing the
issue of america's supply chains so that
we're never again at the mercy of china
or any other nation
is not investing in infrastructure
president disagrees
some don't believe that rebuilding
schools so that they're safe and
asbestos-free
is investing in infrastructure the
president disagrees
and finally some don't think that
building a support system to take care
of
elderly parents or kids with
disabilities at home
so people can go back into the workforce
some of those two million women
who have left the workforce during the
pandemic some think that that is not
investing in
the infrastructure our workforce of this
country that are the backbone of this
country
the president disagrees but with all
that being said
he is welcomes their ideas hopes he puts
them for
hoops they put them forward and he looks
forward to having conversations with
members of both parties about
how to address uh the long outdated
effort to uh
update our infrastructure and then on
mansion is the white house open to
reducing the corporate tax
rate well first the president felt it
was responsible to propose a way to pay
for his proposal
that's exactly what he did he knows some
members think it's too big some think
it's too
too small uh frankly there have been
folks who have come out on both sides of
which we fully expected he knows that
some will come forward with different
ways to pay for this package
and some may have views that it
shouldn't be paid for at all so we fully
expect that from senator manchin
and other members and we expect uh the
question of how to pay for the package
if we should pay for the package to be
part of the discussion moving forward
we're open to hearing ideas and
proposals from members and we
encourage them to put them forward and
then on uh
immigration uh we released a poll
earlier
today that suggests that 25 percent of
americans only 25
approve of the way that the president is
handling the situation at the border
with respect to
unaccompanied minors so does this poll
suggest
that the president needs to reevaluate
his approach to
that issue well if i read the poll
correctly it also had
59 of americans believing that
unaccompanied children should be treated
safely and be protected in that way and
65 percent
supported the reunification of families
there's no question this is a difficult
challenge and the president believes he
was
elected to address hard problems and his
focus
right now is on expediting processing at
the border
opening up additional facilities
addressing the root causes
and uh restarting programs to
incentivize
kids from applying from when within
their countries so that's his focus
right now
is you're just a messaging issue then i
mean how do you explain the fact that
americans are not in favor of what the
president is doing at the border i'm not
sure that's an accurate depiction of the
poll
given uh that there was a about
one-third of the people who replied
didn't have an opinion at all
so that they did not agree though fair
but also a three one-third said they had
no view
so i think that right now our focus is
not on
uh looking at the poll it is on uh
implementing solutions which is no
question uh to address what is
what we view as no question a difficult
challenge uh and
hoping that we can ensure we are
protecting these kids
we are continuing to reassert
to the region the border is not open the
majority of
people adults who come to the border are
turned away
continuing to implement programs in the
region whether it's
working with them to address root causes
or working with them to restart programs
that can help kids from
apply within country that we we feel
those are the ways we can help address
what is no question a challenging issue
go ahead thanks first i want to ask
about the budget
uh what's the hold up on releasing it we
expect it to be soon
uh it's not the full budget as you know
but just for clarity purposes it's
a kind of discretionary guidance um but
uh we hope it to be soon
that it will be soon we expect it to be
very soon i don't have a timeline on
that quite yet
every previous white house has released
at least a bunch of blueprint or an
outline abbreviated budget
by the end of february so what's the
hold up here why is the delay now
stretching in april
well there's no question as we talked
about during the transition that
we dealt with some impactful
intransigence
from the outgoing political appointees
we had some cooperation from the career
staff but we didn't have all of the
information that we needed as you all
know we also don't have a
budget director we have not had a budget
director confirmed we have now an acting
uh budget director which is an important
step forward but again we expect it to
be
soon and as soon as we have a timeline
we will make sure you all know i want to
ask you a question about major league
baseball
the league decided to move its all-star
game out of atlanta
that's something that the president said
he supported before does he
then agree with their decision to move
that game out of atlanta
well i i wish i had had this with me on
friday because i got
asked a question and there's just some
help what i thought would be helpful
context and i know you probably don't
have the transcript in front of you
so when the president was asked during
an espn interview last week
he was asked the question last week
major league baseball players
association executive director said that
he would look forward to discussing move
in the all-star game from atlanta in the
wake of georgia's
governor signing into law a bill passed
by the republican-led state legislature
to overhaul how its state elections run
how do you view this possibility of
moving the all-star game out of georgia
and he said quote
i think today's professional athletes
are acting incredibly responsible
i would strongly support them doing that
so he was not dictating
uh for what major league baseball uh
should do that
that they should dictating they should
move the all-star game uh that is was
their decision
they made that decision and as he stated
earlier he certainly supports that
so he does support the decision to move
well he he supports them being able to
make the decision
and respond to what their players uh act
you know
asks are given many of them are impacted
of course by
these laws okay and then just one more
on vaccines
so there's a report over the weekend
that the governor desantis in florida
had been
dealing with some sort at some sort of
improper dealings with the supermarket
chain publix
as far as distributing the vaccine so
did those reports give the white house
any pause in working with governor
desantis in
the vaccine program uh well
first let me say that for those who
weren't following us in florida
uh one of the concerns we've had as
we've watched the data is that
17 of florida's population is
african-american but less than seven
percent of vaccinations have gone to
african-americans
uh in the state uh that's one of the
reasons that we opened four fema sites
in miami tampa jacksonville and orlando
and these sites disproportionately serve
communities of color so
we've been closely watching this data
and these statistics as we would in any
state across the country
and we took these specific actions for
that purpose um
we are not going to hurt the people of
florida
uh just because of the the steps or
actions of leadership
um and we will continue to take actions
to ensure that
the vaccine is equitably distributed go
ahead
uh just follow up on the baseball
all-star game i know that you've
made the point that he did not dictate
the league
move the all-star game out of georgia
but he likes to say
the words of a president matter he said
he would strongly support if players and
believe wanted to do that
and they did it so does he think
that the pga should move the masters
tournament that begins this week out of
georgia
i'm not here to call for anyone on
behalf of the president or the vice
president or anyone
to take steps in reaction to the law in
georgia
the president was asked a direct
question and the context of the question
was also around
uh the league meeting to discuss this
exact issue and he answered the question
so should we believe that if pga tour
players who are arriving in augusta this
week or today to register for the
tournament that they got together
and decided or talked about not
participating that is something he would
strongly support
or is there anything i'm sure you will
ask me that question or him this
question but
our focus is on doing what we can to
advocate for making voter voting easier
and more accessible
around the country and that's where our
efforts are going to be from the white
house um
before the president said that he would
strongly support moving
the all-star game out of georgia did he
consider the economic impact
because the cobb county tourism ceo is
saying they're going to lose 100 million
dollars
in lost uh business activity 8 000
hotel rooms did he think about that
before he said he would strongly support
the mode
again he was doing an interview he was
given the context as i just read out to
you in full detail of how the question
was asked
he answered the question okay on
immigration 171
000 migrants were caught at the border
in march that's up from 100 000
in february if the trend continues do
you have a sense of how many
migrants the united states can handle
this month well first let me say uh that
there have been numbers that have been
reported out there cbp has not released
their final numbers we expect that to
happen
later this week and for full context
there are numbers that when they release
them will be out
like you cited some version of what you
cited uh but
those are reflecting of people coming
and they we should also be reflecting i
hope i'm encouraging people to do this
people who are turned away because again
uh single adults
uh based on your own reporting and
everyone's reporting continue to be
the vast majority continue to be turned
away at the border i don't have any
predictions about
numbers that will come we're obviously
taking steps as i uh addressed in
a in response to alex's question to uh
address the root causes
put in place programs that people can
utilize to apply from
in country uh send a clear message the
border is not open and that we're
turning away
the majority of adults when they come to
the border
separate report that speaking about the
adults there are a
thousand got aways mostly in arizona
people who
are seen detected but they are not
chased because authorities are so busy
processing the families the washington
post is reporting that some of these
people are carrying drugs
has the administration maybe reached out
to mexico to try to stop
the flow of drugs or help stop the flow
of drugs into
american communities that's always a
part of our diplomatic
conversations uh certainly through the
state department and other entities
within
government i'm happy to check on the
specific reporting i had not seen that
report since before i came out here
great um go ahead kelly in clarifying
today are you trying to roll back what
the president said
about the all-star game no i'm trying to
articulate clearly to everyone
what uh what he said and what the
context of his remarks were
the question that was asked and the full
scope of his answer
and i think it's been shorthanded to no
one's fault because it was it's been
repeated a bit without the full context
and mitch mcconnell says uh that we are
witnessing a coordinated campaign by
powerful and wealthy people
to mislead uh and to use the bully uh
pulpit
about this law will the white house say
explicitly that it is not trying to
influence
corporations or organizations to take
action
on state-level decisions like this we've
conveyed it and i'm happy to answer your
question directly we've not uh
not asked corporations to take specific
actions that's not
uh our focus here our focus is on and
continuing to convey that it's important
that voting is easier not harder
that when there are laws in place that
make it harder we certainly express an
opposition to those laws
couple of foreign policy questions it's
now april 5th
the afghanistan decision is due
soon obviously troops and their families
are interested to know
what the president's decision will be
what more does he need before he can
make or announce this decision
well as the president has said before um
it will be tough to meet the may 1st
deadline for
full withdrawal for logistical reasons
uh we are continuing he's continuing to
consult internally with his national
security
team and advisors and of course also
with our partners and allies and
uh you know he has not he's been working
on these issues foreign policy issues
national security issues for
several decades now and of course wants
to take the time to make the right
decision so our expectation should be
that it will go beyond may first
with the tough to meet portion of your
house you set the expectation it will be
tough for a full withdrawal for
logistical reasons by that timeline and
that certainly has also something that
we've conveyed clearly to our partners
as well uh but in terms of uh what's
next um you know he just wants to take
the time to make
a decision what's the president's level
of concern about what's happening in
jordan
along a an important country an ally and
a buffer against some of the
hotter events in that part of the world
is this
something where he would have any direct
interaction
at this point i would expect it would be
through the state department and
wouldn't expect that
we're of course closely following the
reports out of jordan uh we've been
in touch as an administration with
jordanian officials
king abdullah is a key partner of the
united states he has our full support
go ahead so on ukraine we talked about
this on friday but
the state department has now asked
russia to explain these provocations
does the president have any plans to to
reach out to
president putin on this as it's elevated
to that level of concern
i don't have any calls with president
putin to predict at this point in time
uh last week it was read out that
national
that our secretary of state had a
conversation with his counterpart also
the secretary of defense had a
conversation with his
counterpart uh we remain concerned by
the recent
escalations of russian aggressive
russian aggression and
provocative actions in eastern ukraine
that's something we're watching closely
of course
uh we're aware of their uh the ukrainian
military reports concerning russian
troop movements on ukraine's
border uh but at this point uh we've
been in touch at the secretary of state
and
secretary of defense uh level uh which
is pretty high as we all know uh but i
don't have any
calls from the president to predict for
you just one more uh uh
i of course spoke with the with the
president of ukraine on on friday as
well so that's right
about this specific issue yeah so on the
uh on the front on the tax front um i
understand that you are um you know not
willing to sort of
close in on a specific number that you
might agree with joe with
john engine but have you done a detailed
analysis of what the delta would be
say if you agreed to 25 how much less
income revenue would that distribute are
you doing that kind of a detailed
analysis and preparation for these
negotiations
well i mean first i think it's important
to remind people that the corporate tax
rate we're proposing is lower than it
was
in 2017 in fact it's lower than it was
from world war
ii until 2017. so we are still proposing
a rate
that is lower than it has been for the
vast majority of time
since anyone in this room was alive i
think or around that amount of time
uh so that's our proposal of course what
the president proposed raising it to 28
percent
and and combined with the other tax
proposals would pay for the totality of
the package that's
why he felt it was a responsible
proposal to make
um sorry this person was throwing me off
outside for a second but everything's
fine
um so uh that he thought it was
responsible to me
there will be different ideas for pay
fors right there will be different ideas
for tax proposals
that will all need to be weighed by a
range of questions inclu with congress
and with leaders in congress
and outspoken members in congress about
whether it should be paid for
over what period of time how much should
be paid for what the options are for
paying for it
there are some that are proposing as you
all know salt deductions in other
areas that are not revenue raisers so
this will be all a part of the
discussion and
absolutely our economic team and number
of data crunchers will be crunching
numbers as we proceed but uh we're kind
of in the early stages of these
discussions at this point in time
quickly and omb you mentioned that you
don't have a budget director yet
when do you anticipate that the
president will nominate someone to
replace near attendance
and then i have one more quick
international one sure and i should
have conveyed which i did but i will
reiterate we of course have an acting
omb
director shalon young who is beloved by
capitol hill as you all know um and so
she is of course
playing a very important role but we
didn't have one for some period of time
because she was only recently
confirmed as the deputy and now the
acting i don't have a personal update
for you
in terms of the timeline for nominating
a formally nominating a replacement on
omb
a lot of people have said that they
think young should just get the job i
mean that she should be nominated for
the number one job
can you say anything more on that i
would just say the president thinks so
highly of her that he has nominated her
to serve as the deputy director of omb
which is also an enormous job but i've
been here long enough not to make
predictions of
where he will land on a personnel
announcement international front so the
imf and the world bank are meeting this
week this is a big deal internationally
one of the issues that has come up is is
a sort of a need to expand
the debt relief initiatives to beyond
countries that are just the poorest
countries and there are
significant numbers of countries that
are you know middle-income countries
is this something that the president is
is willing to take on and is this a
message that he wants his
officials to send during these important
meetings
well there's no question that the kova
19 pandemic has deepened global economic
inequality
and as has already been announced by the
treasury department
we are working the u.s the united states
is working with imf management other
members
uh toward a 650 billion dollar general
allocation
uh to imf member countries it's part of
a package of broader international
efforts to support the whole
recovery also includes robust support
for the imf multilateral development
banks
debt relief in some cases all alongside
countries
taking necessary reform steps so we're
working closely with the imf
and other member countries again and we
are all working through uh
the impact of a global pandemic you
don't want to say anything about
expanding the universe of countries that
are going to get help because right now
it's limited to just before
yeah i i would point you to the treasury
department for more specifics beyond
that
uh go ahead and so one thing quickly and
then
uh something else is there any update on
when
uh you or the president will uh release
his latest medical records or any update
on his plans to
visit his medical provider i don't have
an update i'm happy to check with our
team and see if there's one we can
provide you all
uh soon in short order
anything more precise than soon
i'll have to check with the team and
before i give you a specific timeline of
when we'll have that available
back on the mlb question uh given that
as you say the president supports the
ability to make this decision
does he also support other organizations
or businesses
making similar moves which i guess would
broadly be called
bloodhound other events in other states
should they pass similar laws i'm
thinking here of arizona and others that
may be considering similar voting
restriction laws
that's not something we're calling for
from the white house
our focus is on working with congress to
put in place
voting rights legislation working with
leaders in
uh who like stacey abrams and others who
are advocating for
more expanded laws and more expanded
information
out to people to make it easier to vote
so those are really that's really where
our efforts are focused
although i mean some of this may be
moving at a faster
pace in these states then you're going
to be able to get
an omnibus national voting rights law
passed
so there will be moments of inflection
moments here between now and then
where other organizations would be
looking at making the same kinds of
decisions that mlb made
does the president think they should be
able to make those decisions
and to pull out as well i mean broadly
speaking of course the president
and we all believe private sector
entities are going to make decisions
and that's their uh their role to do so
uh what i'm conveying what i can speak
to
is what our focus is on and what our
role is here from the white house and
what his energies will be directed
toward which is
uh voting rights legislation continuing
to voice and advocate for the need to
make it
uh easier and not harder to vote that's
where he will be spending his time and
effort and as will be in the white house
and lastly
on iran with the indirect talks
beginning tomorrow
i mean here it is the first week of
april this is a
foreign policy priority of the
presidents through
throughout the campaign really one of
the very few
specific things he said he wanted to do
is he disappointed that it has taken
this long to get to what isn't even a
face-to-face negotiation
and does he think that there is still
time to pull a deal together before
iranian elections
uh in june well um he knows
from living through it as do you from
covering it for many years that
uh diplomacy can take time and sometimes
it is not at the pace that
everyone would prefer and we certainly
have experience as does he
from having been in the obama biden
administration of the time it took to
work through a diplomatic
process i don't have a prediction to
make in terms of how long it will take
you're right that of course what is
happening uh in the coming
um days is really focused on you know
indirect
that are happening through the europeans
that is still in our view a step forward
toward diplomacy and that remains our
first objective
that the us will not drop any sanctions
until iran
returns to full compliance well his
position hasn't changed on how he's
approaching or we should approach the
negotiations and
we certainly expect that the primary
issues that will be discussed over the
course of the coming days
are the nuclear steps that iran would
need to take in order to return to
compliance
with the terms of the jcpoa and the
sanctions relief steps that you
the united states would need to take in
order to return to compliance as well
but we're just at the beginning of the
talks and uh we don't anticipate
presently
that there will be direct talks between
the united states and iran through this
process though we remain certainly open
to that prospect
go ahead i'll come back to caitlin i'm
sorry go ahead um you mentioned last
week on infrastructure
that you'd like to see progress on the
bill by memorial day
i wonder if you can just define progress
what do you want to see happen by
memorial day
i don't think i'm going to define
progress more than you know we hope
members will be proposing ideas we hope
that there will be
constructive discussions we hope that
they'll be committees meeting
but we'll leave it to hell leadership to
define uh what progress looks like
is this back on senator blunt's proposal
about a smaller package
is it out of the question for the white
house to split up the infrastructure
package or is that something the
customer would be
willing to do well we certainly expect
it and
and it has played out that some will
believe that the
package we proposed is too small some
will believe it's too big
and we're happy to have discussions with
members who have both points of view
but at the end of the day the package
that the president proposed
makes a historic investment in our
nation's infrastructure
rebuilds our economy helps create 19
million jobs
and you know we're hopeful that others
will come forward with ideas that are
as bold and innovative and will help do
the same
uh type of work for american workers in
our economy
and then also just one more um on the
american family's plan
i think you said that you expected that
inviting to talk about that
um sometime at the end of april uh i
just wonder if you can give a specific
timeline on that
and would the strategy there be to try
to cast at the same time with
infrastructure
or would you wait until after an
infrastructure package gets across the
national we're not gonna i'm not gonna
be able to outline the legislative
strategy for a package we haven't
proposed yet but i i said at the time
in the coming weeks uh but i don't have
anything more specific than that at this
point in time
caitlyn just to follow on jordan the
budget
are we not going to get it until there's
a budget director in place
no no i didn't mean to convey that
message he was asking
what the impact what the delay was
caused by and largely it was caused by
intransigence in part during the
transition uh but also we didn't have a
confirmed budget director for
a period of time uh so that is a factor
too so that was answering that part of
his question
the budget before there's actually a
budget well there'll be a couple
different components
and these terms are so um washington but
here we are
so there's the discretionary guidance
which would be the first piece of this
which
would be short not a very long document
a skinny budget and a longer budget so
there's usually a couple different
components
that would come out okay and back on
infrastructure
the white house is saying that they are
open to alternative proposals from other
lawmakers democrats and republicans
but roy blunt has put one forward it's
600 billion dollars it's more
traditional definition
of infrastructure so is the white house
open to anything that he has laid out in
this proposal
or that he says he's pitched directly to
the white house well i think what i was
conveying is that
it's time for people to be bolder um and
more forward-looking about what
infrastructure looks like
infrastructure is not just the roads we
get a horse and buggy across
uh infrastructure is about broadband
it's about replacing lead pipes so
people have
water it's about rebuilding our schools
and so of course we're happy to hear
proposals but uh you know i think this
the definition of infrastructure
we have a disagreement about so what is
the white house's definition of
infrastructure exactly
well i think it's what i went through
earlier when alex um
asked the question which is uh clearly
a number of the items i just talked
about it is rebuilding schools it is
rebuilding our nation's waterways it is
ensuring that we can rebuild pipes so
that
we don't have kids with lead in their
drinking water
it is rebuilding the backbone and the
infrastructure of our workforce because
there are two million women who are out
of the workforce who uh
hopefully if we could help them with
caregiving will be able to rejoin
so there are a number of components that
that i outlined earlier but uh
that we believe define how we can invest
in an innovative forward-looking way in
our economy
in our workers create jobs and that's
the proposal
we put forward and we look forward to
having discussions about so one thing
that senator blunt proposed was paying
for it
and user fees and other revenue streams
that's not raising the corporate tax
rate and in this proposal that we have
from the president
eight years of spending 15 years of
taxes so what happened
what is his defense to lawmakers who ask
what happens when he's not
president and the congress is different
and that they repealed
those tax changes well then then i hope
you'd be asking
um whoever's standing right here who
might be a republican if they ruled them
back
that exact question at the time but our
view is that the corporate tax rate
which again is uh what we were proposing
it be at a rate that is
still lower than it was in 2017 and
lower than it was from between world war
ii and 2017.
our view is that corporations can pay
more
not that it should be on the backs of
consumers and the american people
through user fees which is exactly what
it would be
my last question is on what happened
with johnson and johnson that is this
vaccine being produced at the emergent
plant
in baltimore not too far away of course
we saw what happened
you know last week and over the weekend
where there was a mix-up in
what would have amounted to 15 million
one-shot doses which is a lot for what
we're trying to do
so what was the president's reaction to
that
to the to the news well i would first
say that
the fact that we're not getting 15
million doses right now that
could have been made for american people
it's not exactly what happened because
we are still on track to have the number
of doses we need
to vaccinate all adult americans by the
end of may
this was not even a facility that was
approved by the fda
so we were not betting on these doses we
were betting on doses coming from
moderna pfizer and also johnson johnson
has assured us that we will be getting
the 24 million doses that they have
promised
in april at the same time there were
still steps led through a process by hhs
put in place to take steps over the
weekend
to ensure that johnson johnson is the
only uh
drug that is being produced at the site
given that the issue as you well know
caitlin was about
the cross-contamination of uh
astrazeneca and johnson johnson so there
were still take
steps taken to address this moving
forward but we were not
betting on these to vaccinate the
american public
the adult americans that we have assured
people we will have enough doses by
uh the end of may we remain uh we
continue to believe we will but is he
worried that something like this
happening can
affect vaccine hesitancy that we're
already seeing in the united states
well we haven't seen that uh to date but
this is why the fda approval process is
in place
uh in many ways it was the process
working because the fda had not approved
this site
there were steps taken to address what
some of the issues were
and we also have a range of contingency
plans you know when when we all talk in
here about
why did we order so many doses why are
we at the point where we are sharing
doses with every country around the
world
part of it is because we need to plan
for things coming up things like this
come up
uh this is obviously as you noted a big
number of doses but there are we have to
plan for a range of
contingencies that's exactly what we did
that's uh one of the many reasons that
we're going to still be in a place where
we have enough vaccines for
adult americans by the end of may go
ahead
what is the structure does the president
support the idea of a possible second
reconciliation
if the white house proposal does not
receive any republican support
well we believe with 80 of the public
supporting infrastructure investment
with even proposals coming forward
supporting components of the package
that if we start on areas where we agree
we can move forward with bipartisan
support and any more background you can
provide on which lawmakers specifically
republicans the white house is reaching
out to and inviting
to to the white house for meetings not
yet i'm i'm sure when we have a meeting
set and we have the members all
confirmed we'll share
the names with you of course once that's
done on coven with the rise of new
variants
is the administration investing in
booster shots or ramp
up in production of booster shots or
research and development
for new vaccine to deal with the many
variants
sure well one of the issues that we've
been focused on is
again ensuring that we have flexibility
as it relates to vaccine
doses that we have ordered that could
include now the fda is still going
through the pot the process
of approval for booster shots and
determining of course what's needed and
when we would we would leave it to them
and the cdc of course
to make that determination an
announcement but we do have flexibility
in the doses we've purchased
moving forward should that be a need to
clarify that point is operation work
speed still in effect or would this be a
continuation
of that to address the investment
in additional vaccine well
companies are still are producing uh
booster shots and options they're being
uh you know they're being reviewed by
the fda
so i'm not sure that's just a process
that's ongoing with companies in hhs
go go ahead oh sorry let me let me just
get around to everybody and they'll come
back go ahead
yeah uh chief of staff ron klain said
last week that president biden has asked
the u.s department of education to
prepare a memo
on the president's legal authority to
cancel student debt
uh what exactly has the white house
asked for here
and in the past uh president biden has
said he would be prepared to write off
ten thousand dollars in debt
but not fifty thousand like some
liberals and democrats
um have asked for is biden rethinking
his position
and is he reconsidering his position on
the idea of cancelling
uh debt of students who attended more
expensive private schools
well first um he continues to look
look forward to he'd welcome a bill
signed by or passed by congress i should
say
to cancel ten thousand dollars in
student debt uh and he'd be happily
signed that
i think that would naturally be the
first step before it's a larger amount
beyond there
what ron clean was referring to is the
fact that there's an ongoing review
it's both a policy review and a legal
review so
department of education and department
of justice to look at what the options
are
and what authority could be recommended
to the president so that was the process
he was referring to
he's asking what options are available
does that mean whether he can do it to
fifty thousand dollars
and does that mean that it's therefore
open as a possibility for the white
house
yeah it's his paul his position hasn't
changed there's a review to
take a look at uh at um what is possible
with executive authority
he doesn't think that's a good proposal
during the town hall back in february
he very much certainly you know was that
outspoken against the fifty thousand
dollar
threshold so where does he stand on that
at this point and again uh
after that point in time ron clayne and
others have spoken with
a range of leaders in congress and we've
said many times from this podium that
there is an ongoing review
of what the options are that are
possible under executive authority
there's also a policy review as would be
expected at the same time
we haven't ruled out options but that
review is ongoing there isn't a
conclusion of it
let me just go ahead all right thanks um
i have an infrastructure
and a baseball question here okay um so
last week the white house put out a fact
sheet about the infrastructure plan
that cited the texas power outage excuse
me as evidence of the urgent
need to modernize the the nation's
electric grid
which kind of leaves the implication
that texas will get funding
to upgrade its trade but i haven't seen
that specifically so
can you offer assurance that there
actually would be money in this
for texas to modernize upgrade whether
it's it's not
this is believe it or not oh you will
believe it of course a very common
question from a lot of reporters and
media outlets across the country
we will we will have some state fact
sheets i expect soon that kind of break
down some of the specifics there are
pieces like broadband access and other
things
but there'll be a competitive bidding
process once the bill is signed into law
and we'll probably won't have more to
say that specifically until then
actually that that's i think that's a
really um vague part of the plan
what do you mean by a competitive
bidding process is this like
how do the top bridges or power grids
get
chosen i mean is it a form do you
envision a formula
based on state population or is
a federal department deciding which is a
more critical project than another
it's we're not quite there yet we just
proposed this a couple of days ago
a competitive bidding process which i
think most americans would support
would mean that states entities have to
apply for funding
for rebuilding the infrastructure in
their states
and through local communities or
whatever it may be what the tenants and
the specific
logistics of that competitive bidding
process would be
i'm sure there'll be discussions members
will have different views they'll all be
advocating for different projects
we certainly expect that but we're in
the early stages of the process and
so these congressional meetings these
are not about putting specific projects
on a list
no baseball question is um today's
home opener for the texas rangers is the
first major league sports event
since the pandemic started that that
allows an
open a full a full house the president
called that a mistake last week
has he spoken to other team owners
to try to deter them and get them to
hold off from having full house
events i don't have any calls from the
president to baseball team owners to
to read out i would say that the
president continues to reiterate the
need to follow public health guidelines
there are restrictions as you well know
recommended including unmasking
social distancing which of course
applies to having a full stadium
and the importance of being vigilant
even while we're at war with this virus
we have seen spikes in certain
parts of the country certain regions in
the country that's something we're
closely watching
and just a reminder of how important it
is to be vigilant
very last question are any federal
assets going to be used to track
whether this event actually does lead to
a spike
i would send that question to the cdc uh
go ahead
thank you very much then i have a
question about immigration
president biden has spoken publicly
about how during the obama
administration
he worked with central american
countries and let's talk about how he
was um helped negotiate getting 700
million dollars in aid to
help those countries prevent the flow of
migrants coming north
what lessons did the president learn
from that experience that he's applying
to
dealing with the crisis now well i think
one of the reasons the president asked
and tell me if this is answering a
question but
one of the reasons the president asked
his vice president to play a similar
role that he played
is because he recognizes that unless we
address the root causes in these
countries
unless we disincentivize uh young people
families leaving these countries we
improve the economic conditions
we create spaces for them to be in these
countries that
avoids the corruption that is in place
in many of the governments
we will continue to go through cycle
after cycle some of these programs and
obviously the funding was not advanced
during the last administration
and some of the programs were reversed
so you know his
experience impacts him and affects him
because he knows
we need to address the current
challenges we're having at the border
those are immediate but in order to
address it longer term
we need to address the root causes in
the countries is his equitation
snapping back the funding that was cut
during the
administration or are there additional
things that he's expecting to see
implement in the region well he's
proposed four billion dollars in funding
in his immigration proposal
so he certainly believes that we need
more um it's not just reinstituting
programs
we also need more need to build from
there and he expects to of course be
briefed by
our envoy who's uh going to be back and
forth in the region
others will be involved and of course
the vice president will be uh very
closely involved in these conversations
as well
we expect on climate when can we expect
to see the u.s
commitments under the paris agreement
that the u.s
announced it was re-entered on february
4. when can the public see
what those u.s commitments are going to
look like when well i expect when we
have our climate summit in a couple of
weeks there'll be an update
we'll discuss more on a big national
stage or the bully pulpit um what where
we are going from here where we are
where we're going from here and
of course gina mccarthy and other
members of our climate team uh
former secretary john kerry are hard at
work on
uh putting together plans and working to
implement go ahead
thank you again two questions uh first
in response to kelly's question earlier
you reiterated the us's strong support
for jordan and for king abdullah is a
strong ally
now the reports about the arrest of the
deposed crown prince
and 20 others are now 24 hours old
has the president made any calls to the
king and upon reiterating that support
i don't have any calls to read out what
i tried to convey to kelly was that
those calls or those engagements would
likely happen out of the state
department at this point
all right the other thing on the
infrastructure package there is
a private memo that's being circulated
in the business community
and to some republican senators that
said that the
2.25 trillion dollar price tag
is 1 trillion off and that there's many
things in there that were
omitted in the initial discussion of the
bill notably
the um 300 billion dollar
uh energy tax credit the 100 billion
dollars for the green bank
and that these things would add one
trillion dollars to it
this is being circulated up the hill do
you have any response to the charge that
the president
low ball the price tag on the
infrastructure
sounds mysterious the memo the secret
memo
is are you saying to understand your
question are you saying there are things
the president didn't put in his proposal
people think he's going to add to his
proposal
no there's things there that somebody
went through it or is claiming to have
gone through it and
added it up and came up with one
trillion more than the president
uh listed as the price tag so it is
actually 3.25 trillion
as opposed to we laid out very
specifically
each component of the package and how
much we're proposing so
i would encourage you all to get your
calculators out and
charge that up and see how it compares
to the to the secret memo
oh wait go ahead in the back and then we
can come back around to the front but i
think you can
um updated the co-favorite uh
related travel guidance last friday is
the administration considering losing
some international travel restrictions
i don't have anything to predict on that
front obviously that would be done by
our health and medical
experts and we would refer to them for
any
timeline on the guidelines will you
accept
other vaccines that are approved by
other countries that's not
appropriate fda yet will we accept them
here in the united states
yeah as like um qualified uh vaccines
uh i may not be totally understanding
your question we we have we are
we have ordered supply from the three
vaccines that have been approved by the
fda
that's what we're focused on
distributing to the american public
uh so i would anticipate we continue to
focus on the
vaccines that are fda approved glad
you've been very patient thanks
uh that's a follow-up to caitlin's
question okay on emergence
sure and that's about what does it mean
now that j j is
sort of taking over that facility
wholesale what does that mean for the
astrozetica vaccine
and will it affect their ability to
manufacture here in the united states
over that production
domestically now shrink well um
first um we're working with astrazeneca
to
immediately immediately identify other
facilities to continue their domestic
manufacture of astrazeneca drug
substance and several options are under
consideration
as you know it hasn't been approved
after seneca through the fda
yet johnson johnson has hence the
importance of johnson and johnson
production continuing to be expedited
sure
go ahead so a small question just trying
to make certain i understand
where you are with taxation on the
individual level on friday in the
president's remarks in the state dining
room
he said i will raise a penny tax on a
family making less than 400 000 a year
last week there were some questions
about this you also included individuals
so is it families joint filers
individuals
is that threshold determined uh it is he
will not raise taxes on any individual
or family making more than four hundred
thousand dollars a year
uh we expect there'll be more specifics
on
uh what he's proposing some of the
things that he's talked about on the
campaign trail
uh as it relates to individuals as we
get closer to the roll out of the
family's plan go ahead
zoe that's you thank you um
so in california as the school districts
decide
how to be open the united teachers of
los angeles union uh their members are
asking for free
child care for their own kids for the
teachers kids
to go back that that is something that
they should get
i i would point you to the state of
california and the local school
districts to have those discussions and
then just one more
quick one on georgia to put on it um
is the president going to change the way
that he talks
about the new georgia voting law because
in that interview that he referenced he
said the law would end voting at five
o'clock when working people are just
getting off and he said it would end
voting hours early so working
people can't have their vote after their
shift is over but at the washington post
pay that claim for pinocchio's because
that part of the law gives counties the
option to
extend the white hours and so i'm just
curious
if the president is going to change the
way they want to talk
well fundamentally the president doesn't
believe it should be made harder
to vote he believes it should be easier
and this bill makes it harder to request
and return an absentee ballot
it collapses the length of georgia's
runoff election making it harder for
large jurisdictions to offer early
voting
it imposes rigid new restrictions on
local officials ability to set polling
hours to suit the needs of voters in
their county
those are all pieces of the bill so his
view is that we need to make it easier
and not harder to vote and that will
continue to be what he advocates for
but the thing he said has been
determined by
election law experts to be not true
so i'm just curious if he's going to
stop saying
well again i think we can uh the fact
checkers will also
tell you that uh this bill does not make
it easier for people across
the state of georgia to vote and that's
where he has concerns
go ahead and send my conductors um
you've got this april 12th meeting up
with
uh coming up with senior uh officials
but also from industry
can you give us a list of companies that
will be participating in that
and then there was a report out on
japanese media saying that the president
and the japanese prime minister were
working toward an agreement of supply
chain
um during the supply chain for
semiconductors
can you say anything more about what
you're whether there is some kind of
agreement in the works
and what you're expecting to come out of
both of those meetings
uh well first i expect when we get
closer to the meeting we will have and
leave a confirmed list of participants
we will share the list of
companies and participants with you but
probably not until we get much closer to
that actual
meeting as it relates to japan as we've
made clear
the us japan alliance is a cornerstone
of peace security and prosperity
in the region uh and that is one of the
reasons why
we're working to deepen our close
coordination across a variety of areas
including
supply chains as secretary of state
lincoln discussed with his counterpart
last month but in terms of specifics of
those discussions and what's possible in
the future
i just don't have anything to preview
for you at this point in time
yeah the president does acknowledge that
the new law
doesn't change election day voting hours
right
uh well look caitlyn it also doesn't
expand them
uh for early voting and makes early
voting shorter
so there are a lot of components of the
legislation he is concerned about and
that's what he was expressing right
he does acknowledge that because his
comments have been confusing
about closing it at 5 pm that's correct
that it doesn't i think what's important
is to report on
all the components that make it more
difficult to vote in the package in the
legislation
all right so we have a special guest i
will say that we
know that this is one of the events
where people get to take their children
family members friends too and it's not
quite the same we'll do a big one next
year but we still wanted to have a
visitor
and some special commemorative easter
eggs for all of you from
um from the president and the first lady
uh not today but we'll invite the bunny
back for a future briefing as always
but the bunny's wearing a mask where you
we take no
use every opportunity
it does not look similar but we'll have
to fact
check that for you different eyelashes
are we giving those out yes we're going
to save them with chris
all right chris is going to be the
bunny's helper
he will be delivering uh eggs and make
sure each of you get one and some
chocolates to take home to your loved
ones
thank you everyone
thank you very much